i
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a el debate soy
santiago lópez gonzález la llamada
segunda ola o rebrote de la pandemia del
corona virus está afectando
principalmente al continente europeo
sobre todo a sus principales centros
urbanos las autoridades temen que la
situación se salga completamente de
control o escale a los niveles que
vivieron españa e italia en el primer
semestre del 2020 es por este motivo que
están recurriendo a todo tipo de medidas
para frenar el avance del virus y
mantener a flote las economías de los
diferentes países del continente esto
parece ser un deja vú parece ser algo
que ya vivimos al principio de este año
2020 veamos algunos datos los países más
afectados en europa en su orden son
rusia españa francia reino unido e
italia solamente por mencionar los cinco
más afectados
hay preocupación por el rápido avance
también en otros países como la
república checa portugal los países
bajos y suecia vemos un vistazo entonces
a algunas de las cifras más relevantes
en el continente europeo al cierre de la
jornada de hoy españa cuya capital
madrid es una de las ciudades europeas
más afectadas registra más de 800 88 mil
casos francia en donde temen una rápida
saturación de las salas de cuidado
intensivo reportan allí 700 más de 776
mil casos italia que fue el primer foco
del brote a principio de año tiene 356
mil casos registrados
alemania tiene más de 332 mil casos y es
también uno de los países en donde más
rápido se está extendiendo esta segunda
ola
pese a que muchos de estos países tienen
un robusto sistema de salud tienen una
buena red hospitalaria y el teletrabajo
en muchos casos ya estaba instaurado
antes de la pandemia las autoridades no
han demorado en imponer algunas
restricciones demos un vistazo en
francia- ya hay ocho ciudades entre
ellas parís la capital en estado de
alerta máxima con restricciones tanto en
el comercio como en los restaurantes y
los bares en alemania el gobierno dejó
que los estados federados y que las
alcaldías de algunas ciudades y
poblaciones impongan restricciones
dependiendo de la situación que se está
viviendo allí por eso berlín ahora tiene
un 'toque de queda' de 11 de la noche a
6 de la mañana esto ha llevado a que
haya algunas contradicciones
malentendidos por parte de los
ciudadanos porque las leyes varían de
estado en estado y de ciudad en ciudad
ya lo decíamos berlín y la ciudad de
frankfurt que es un importante centro
financiero pues tienen un toque de queda
nocturno mientras que italia fue
impuesto recientemente también un 'toque
de queda' a nivel nacional para que los
restaurantes y los bares cierren a
partir de la medianoche hasta primeras
horas de la mañana eso sí dijeron
las escuelas van a permanecer abiertas
para que los estudiantes puedan seguir
asistiendo a clases presenciales
en la mayoría de los países sigue siendo
obligatorio el uso de la mascarilla y el
mayor temor radica en la llegada del
invierno boreal las gripes las gripes
estacionales aunque ya el hemisferio sur
aquí en la zona de sur américa varios
países como argentina uruguay chile
bolivia y brasil ya vivieron esta
primera parte del rebrote en pleno
invierno austral así que alguna elección
podemos enseñar desde esta parte del
mundo al norte de nuestro planeta para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
daniel lópez acuña él es médico
epidemiólogo ex director del director
del departamento de acción sanitaria en
situación de crisis de la organización
mundial de la salud está en la ciudad de
gijón en españa y también está con
nosotros manuel frías vargas él es
médico de familia del sistema madrileño
de salud es experto en prevención global
de riesgo vascular él se une a esta
conversación desde la ciudad de madrid
la capital española ustedes también
pueden ser parte de este debate dejen
sus comentarios en las redes sociales no
se encuentran como arroba france24 yo en
el piso s arroba sant y luego y la
y que está el numeral el debate efe 24
pues comienzo entonces con daniel
preguntándole en si era de alguna forma
evitable este segundo rebrote en europa
de esta magnitud que está teniendo si
bien es mucho menor al primero que
tuvimos en el primer semestre del 2020
las cifras preocupan a los gobiernos y
sobre todo pone en alerta los sistemas
de salud
si lo primero es señalar que las cifras
que estamos observando en estos momentos
no son exactamente comparables a las
cifras que observamos en la primavera
entre la primavera boreal entre marzo y
junio por una razón y es que estamos
haciendo muchas más pruebas diagnósticas
en estos momentos que nos permiten ver
una parte mayor del haysbert que lo que
veíamos en su xi en el de los meses de
marzo a junio hubiésemos hecho la
cantidad de pruebas que hacemos hoy el
número de casos podría haber sido casi
diez veces mayor que lo que observamos
encima entonces esto es simplemente para
contextualizar el hecho de que esta fase
de repuntes del verano tardío y el
comienzo del otoño lo que estamos
viviendo en europa
no necesariamente tiene la misma
magnitud almas que no necesariamente
tienen la misma intensidad que lo visto
en la primavera si bien esto no debe ser
causa para que los hermanos en nuestros
laureles o pensemos que todo está
resuelto hay que preocuparse con estos
nuevos repuntes que se han producido en
europa ciertamente es el caso para
españa' requiere de una acción decisiva
para frenar esta esta comisión para
doblegar la curva de la pandemia y en
estos momentos estamos empeñados en ello
si bien debemos entender que una parte
no digo que todo lo que estamos
observando en estos repuntes del verano
se debe fundamentalmente a que relajamos
excesivamente nuestras conductas
pensamos que el virus ya no está ahí
sino nos ayudamos en que había que
seguir manteniendo las medidas de
restricciones para el uso de la
mascarilla y sobre todo
agruparse en obtener correos no tener
grandes congregaciones de personas
al hacerlo de esa manera pues estamos
hoy pagando la factura de las medidas
restrictivas que no tomamos pero claro
también necesitamos mantener la guardia
en alto con respecto a las acciones
sanitarias de detección precoz de
rastreo de aislamientos positivos y eso
es muy importante en esta fase en un
repunte como en un caso de españa- clase
dineral en columna manuel fría su
opinión era posible evitar un poco este
segundo rebrote o es parte simplemente
del proceso que hay que tener en cuenta
cuando se analizan estas pandemias o
estas epidemias como ya no lo ha
indicado la historia en el pasado había
simplemente dejar que este curso tuviera
lugar
así es yo apunto al doctor lópez acuña
de que realmente nos hemos confiado
demasiado en las medidas restrictivas
que nos dieron que creíamos que el virus
haya desaparecido
había desaparecido pero es importante
también concretar de que los gobiernos y
los gestores los directivos deben de ser
transparentes y sobre todo ser lo más
coherente y coordinar y evitar mensajes
cruzados entre los expertos y portavoces
como estamos viendo ahora en españa en
las diferentes comunidades autónomas
daniel lópez en la ciudad de gijón en
este segundo brote según lo que han
indicado los primeros estudios tal
parece que ha mutado en cierta forma
porque antes en el primer brote en la
primavera de ustedes se verían más
afectadas las personas con algunas
condiciones médicas previas y personas
mayores vimos los casos en los hogares
de retiro y ancianatos en europa ahora
los jóvenes también están empezando a
padecer el kobe 19 hay una diferencia
entre este brote y el anterior
pero las diferencias que existen desde
un punto de vista fisiológico no es
porque haya existido una mutación que
nos esté dando una enfermedad diferente
es porque el comportamiento
epidemiológico ha sido distinto en el
siguiente sentido una vez que se abatió
la curva en la primavera o al final de
la primavera lo que tuvimos fue una
permanencia residual del virus y luego
al relajar las conductas tuvimos un
circuito de transmisión mucho más
intensificado entre personas jóvenes
estaban siendo parte del ocio nocturno
de la actividad más relajada de las
congregaciones y celebraciones y esto
nos dio una primera aproximación al
contagio de los meses de verano que era
fundamentalmente en personas más jóvenes
pero evidentemente esto no se ha
detenido ahí y esto ha ido recorriendo
los espectros de edad aceptan mucho más
en estos momentos a personas también de
edades medias y personas mayores las
personas que están siendo ingresada
en hospitales o en unidades de cuidados
intensivos son personas de edad más
avanzada en las personas jóvenes tiende
a ser un cuadro de carácter asintomático
no siempre hay casos también quieren
nuestra pensión pero no es que sea una
enfermedad diferente es que a tener una
dinámica de transmisión diferente y hoy
estamos viendo reportes que nos sitúan
en los umbrales de lo que tuvimos en
primavera-verano y por eso tenemos que
tener tanto vida
doctor frías su opinión al respecto su
opinión sobre esta este notorio
incremento de los casos en los jóvenes
ya lo explicaban un poco pasó el verano
muchos se tomaron algunas licencias
entonces ahora cómo manejar la situación
por ejemplo aquí en madrid especialmente
en atención primaria que es un área
donde donde trabajo a diario en la
práctica clínica todos los días pues
esencialmente es lo que vemos pacientes
entre 15 59 años con patológica sin
patología y con una sintomatología leve
o generalmente asintomática ahora se
están viendo brotes también en sitios
universitarios donde realmente estos
jóvenes en muchas ocasiones pues se
divierten muchas veces con el virus y
creen que que no le va a perjudicar y
creen que son inmunes no yo creo que lo
más que lo más importante es que en
atención primaria estamos viendo estos
casos no lo más graves y especialmente
de que la atención primaria y
especialmente en madrid y en muchas
otras comunidades autónomas es muchas
veces
lo invisible en nosotros lo que ve la
gente
pero en atención primaria realmente
vemos todos los casos y la gran mayoría
de casos graves o creemos que pueden
tener una gravedad importante son
derivados al hospital doctor enfría sigo
con usted para tocar otro tema
hoy vimos en los medios europeos que
muchos mencionaban el caso de esta mujer
negarla antes a 89 años que falleció el
día de hoy tras haber sufrido cobit y
haber sido re infectada otra vez en este
segundo brote vuelve a poner sobre la
mesa entonces la preocupación de una
reinfección de una de un segundo caso en
algunos pacientes hasta ahora hay 25
reportados en todo el mundo esto es algo
de lo que nos debemos comenzar a
preocupar sobre todo aquí en américa
latina donde estamos esperando que ya la
segunda ola llegue en algún par de meses
creo que estos casos al igual como en
méjico en el día de hoy que hemos visto
una coinfección con la gripe creo que
estos casos y así lo vamos ir viendo en
la medida de lo posible son casos
esporádicos y yo creo que hay que estar
y ver genéticamente si es el mismo vídeo
es totalmente diferente yo creo que hay
que tener
hay que tener una cautela y no dejarse
llevar de estas cosas que podríamos
tener en el día con la segunda ola y los
brotes que puede haber en los países
europeos cautela yo creo que hay que
tener mucha cautela en decir que es una
reinfección lo más importantes y que
durante ahora que nosotros vamos a vivir
la epidemia
hay otros países europeos que están
empezando con los brotes y que
probablemente y que probablemente esta
gripe también esté al mismo tiempo que
el coronavirus que la cob y 19 yo creo
que lo más importante es incitar a las
personas personas que se vacunen y
pacientes de riesgo con una morbilidad
con una patología es importante es que
puedan vacunar y tener en cuenta esta
vacunación con todos los brotes que
pueden venir en el en el tiempo que
vamos a ver señor lópez el doctor fidel
nos indicaba y nos habla de estas gripes
estacionales que van están por llegar a
europa por la misma llegada del invierno
como es habitual en esta época la
influenza es prácticamente una
obligación para muchos de los ciudadanos
europeos vacunarse en esta época contra
contra este virus algo enseño suramérica
en este tipo de manejo porque sudamérica
ya salió del invierno le tocó la parte
más dura del brote del corona virus
vemos que argentina sigue todavía en el
confinamiento pero
regiones del sur del país siguen
haciendo frente a altos cantidad de
casos reportados que puede aprender a
europa para enfrentar el invierno del
caso sudamericano
bueno yo no quiero una pandemia como la
que vivimos todos los países tenemos que
aprender del todo europa de américa
américa de europa asia de áfrica y
áfrica de asia y yo creo que en estos
momentos lo que tenemos que entender es
que en aquellos lugares los nominados
temporadas estacionales que están
asociadas con la gripe estacional la
influenza
tienen que tomarse medidas extremas para
primero asegurarse que no exista una
presión asistencial excesiva por kobe 19
que genere una ocupación de camas sobre
salas circulados intensivos que puedan
poner en entredicho la posibilidad de
atender adecuadamente los cuadros de
influenza segundo que hay que vacunar a
toda la población vulnerable y tener las
coberturas de vacunación para la gripe
estacional tan altas como sea
para proteger a las personas tenemos la
ventaja por el gripe estacional de que
tenemos una vacuna a diferencia en el
cob y tonto también a mantener
lo que no queremos es que se nos solapen
las cargas asistenciales de la gripe con
la el con la coenzima que no se nos
llenen los hospitales de las dos patas y
que no se nos llenen las unidades de
cuidados intensivos de las dos patas y
no es únicamente la coinfección es sobre
todo la coexistencia joya de la maría en
solapamiento de la carga de enfermedad
que pueden suponer la una y la otra para
el sistema asistencial y el riesgo que
tiene esto de colapsar por eso las
medidas tienen que saber en algunos
casos de comienza autónomas se han
tomado las medidas de adelantar la
vacunación de hacer toda la diseminación
posible para incrementar las coberturas
de vacunación y yo creo que en estos
momentos es fundamental que se trabaje
de esa manera como en su momento al
repetirse un ciclo invernal en el caso
de américa del sur cuando se venga este
momento y si todavía seguimos con
avanzada importante de la cob inglés y
mario porque no tengamos una báculo será
muy importante hacer lo mismo
prevenir al máximo la saturación
hospitalaria
y general toda la cobertura posible de
vacunación de las poblaciones
vulnerables a la condición señor lópez y
todas las medidas son justificadas y
pueden funcionar para para poder hacer
frente a este rápido contagio que está
teniendo europa entre esas el
confinamiento que es tan criticado tan
señalado que en algunos casos funcionó
fue respetado en otros no la oms se ha
dicho que el regreso en confinamiento
debe ser la última opción que puede
haber para hacer frente este segundo a
este segundo brote qué opinión tiene
usted al respecto
y yo creo que hay que contextualizar muy
bien en estas citas que a veces se hacen
ayer el director general de 9 meses hizo
una declaración diciendo hay situaciones
en donde no hay más remedio que quedarse
en casa es decir que con final te
pongamos de esta manera y en una ante
una pandemia en donde no tenemos un
abajo donde no tenemos tratamientos
efectivos y en donde se produce una
incidencia acumulada alta y una tasa de
transmisión ante en donde ya no sólo
tenemos brotes y no tenemos transmisión
comunitaria los confinamientos pueden
ser 16 en propio fondo monetario
internacional declaró hace un par de
días que era preferible tener un
confinamiento corto pero efectivo que
permita restablecer los circuitos de la
actividad económica a tener unas fases
de arranque y frenado en tira y afloja
que no nos llevaría a ningún a ningún
lado y que serían contra cruces
yo creo que
lo que tenemos que entender todos es que
tenemos que hacer simultáneamente
restricciones a la movilidad ya la
agrupación de personas a las actividades
masivas a la falta de protección a
instancias físicas y con mascarillas y
al mismo tiempo tenemos que entender que
extremar las medidas de diagnóstico
precoz de detección temprana de los
casos de seguimiento y rastreo de los
contactos de los casos de diagnóstico
con pruebas de pcr diagnósticas y de
aislamiento de las personas positivas
que es lo que nos va a disminuir la
posibilidad de transmisión pero es la
acción combinada y hay situaciones en
donde las restricciones y el
confinamiento no no no son negativos son
totalmente necesarios y en la de bera
bera vivimos con toda claridad que en el
momento en que se produjo la restricción
de la movilidad y los confinamientos
ante la gran explosión de la curva
epidémica
blanca a lo largo de una semana y media
dos a lo largo de casi 15 días la curva
caía drástica entonces nadie quiere
llegar al confinamiento europa pero no
tenemos que descartar porque puede ser
absolutamente necesario para frenar una
alta formación doctor frías a todas
estas medidas y restricciones y posibles
medidas para hacer frente a esta segunda
ola hay que sumar un factor muy
importante y es la disciplina ayuda
ciudadana la disciplina que tienen los
habitantes en españa ha sido criticada
también incluso en la unión europea se
se pidió que fueran más estrictos a la
hora de imponer las medidas porque la
gente muchas veces no la respetaba en
américa latina ha pasado lo mismo en
algunos lados las respetan y esto ha
puesto sobre la mesa ese tema la
disciplina ciudadana como la evalúa
usted
hoy en día es el sistema o mejor dicho
las personas que realizan lo de las
ventajas de las mascarillas o mejor
dicho la forma de cómo llevar las
mascarillas y de las formas del modelo
de la mejor manera de las mascarillas yo
creo que es importante tener en cuenta
que las mascarillas no se pueden llevar
en el modo que las mascarillas se deben
llevar en la boca los tapabocas que
tienen que llevarse tapando toda la boca
y toda la nariz y en el día de hoy en
aquí en españa los organismos públicos
pues han realizado las formativas y
cuáles mascarillas realmente cumplen
estas normativas y cuáles no estamos
viendo de qué muchas veces nos las
pasamos
es decir que pasamos por alto que las
mascarillas deben de ser utilizadas y lo
más importante es que comentando lo que
decía el doctor lópez acuña es que las
medidas deben ser cortas y deben ser
decisivas y sobre todo aspirar al máximo
del nivel de edad de las recomendaciones
y las restricciones a toda la población
sí doctor frías y usted su en su
práctica diaria en sus consultas diarias
usted como evalúa en vuelvo y reitero en
el tema de la disciplina estaría la
gente es reticente a utilizar las
mascarillas a tener que respetar
confinamientos o cuando ya se dio puerta
abierta para para poder tener una vida
un poco más en espacios abiertos durante
el verano la gente simplemente se relajó
por completo como lo ve usted con las
personas que usted ha tenido a lo largo
de estos meses en su consulta
si en la consulta de atención primaria
que realizó hemos inclusive comentado y
dado por enterado de salud pública de
madrid porque hay personas que se restan
se resistían a llevar un confinamiento
de 14 días cuando llevábamos los 14 días
de confinamiento o de aislamiento
hemos comentado a las personas que
entran al centro de salud al centro de
salud las formas las maneras más
correctas llevar las mascarillas en el
centro de salud por ejemplo que trabajos
en el centro de salud comillas aquí en
madrid y hay zonas que nosotros llevamos
kobe que serían las personas que van a
hacerse una evaluación porque tienen
síntomas que podrían tener que tendrían
que ser evaluados y aquellas personas
que consideramos en un momento dado por
la sintomatología y por la por las
preguntas que se le hace de triaje
consideramos que son pacientes uno joven
la gran mayoría de pacientes por por por
en nuestro centro de salud pues lo
llevaban bien en las restricciones y lo
más importante yo creo que es ser
consciente de que estas restricciones en
algún momento y nos servirán para
disminuir y para la curva se tenga mucho
menos de la que tenemos ahora en los
brotes sean mucho menos conciencia me
quedo con esa palabra doctor frías
señor lópez la conciencia eso tal vez ha
costado también un poco a los gobiernos
para llevar el mensaje puntualmente a
sus ciudadanos a sus poblaciones y vemos
en ciudades como berlín parís en madrid
manifestaciones de ciudadanos que
rechazan las medidas dicen que todo esto
de la pandemia es un invento que es algo
que no existe que simplemente quieren
hacer una cierta limpieza de la sociedad
mundial y hay un montón de teorías de
especulación que le dice usted a estas
personas
bueno lamentablemente tenemos estos
grupos de negacionistas en cancún
asimismo con respecto a las vacunas como
a la existencia de la pandemia como la
importancia y las medidas de protección
y yo lamentablemente tengo que
inevitablemente comparar a esta reacción
o si estos flujos de personas con el
peor oscurantismo medieval que
pudiéramos estar distribuyendo
estas personas tienen que ser
responsables y tienen que tener una
noción de lo que es un comportamiento
solidario y sipe y responsable
civilmente con relación a la salud de
sus congéneres y sus considerandos pero
no la tienen entonces tenemos ahí un
movimiento muy importante que atenta que
mina las acciones de salud pública yo
creo que bueno además de que tenemos que
maximizar la pedagogía social para que
se entienda lo que ocurre y la
importancia de la responsabilidad
individual y colectiva bueno tenemos que
con todas las armas posibles frenar este
avance de los movimientos negacionistas
que sólo están haciéndole daño a burton
que hay que hay señor lópez de el tema
de las vacunas johnson y johnson anunció
que detuvo su investigación por
complicaciones que ha tenido con algunas
de las de las personas voluntarias tal
parece que la vacuna se va a demorar más
hay mucha expectativa a la gente está
esperando la vacuna para el fin de año o
principios del 2021 cree usted que se va
a demorar más de lo que estamos
esperando
bueno yo creo que hemos corrido
demasiado para tratar de ver que se
llegue a la vacuna todos deseamos que la
vacuna esté disponible y que esté lista
una vacuna eficaz y segura no cualquier
vacuna una vacuna que no haga daño y que
mis pero bueno estos procesos toman
tiempo todas las vacunas en las más
avanzadas en su desarrollo están aún en
fase 3 que implica una prueba en casos
reales con personas que sin ser ministra
hay personas a las que no se les
administra la vacuna para
garantiza tengamos eficacia popular que
la alguna renuncia inicia y proteger y
garantizar seguridad que no haya efectos
colaterales que vayan a ver hemos
observado ya en cuando menos dos casos
de dos tipos de vacunas que habría que
interrumpir los procesos desde hace tres
pues porque surgen casos de
complicaciones asociadas a la prueba
esto no es no es inusual no es que sea
anormal en las fases 3 de la prueba de
medicamentos las vacunas los demás es
que estamos ahora con la lupa muy puesta
casi en tiempo real y no estamos
aguardando a que se complete en los
procesos yo lo que sé repetidamente
enseñar lo es
necesitamos la paciencia cautela no
pensar que esto es una carrera a la luna
o carrera armamentista y entender que
una vez que se tenga la seguridad y la
eficacia de uno o más productos también
tendremos que producirse las poblaciones
y esto nos puede situar todavía en el
primer semestre
el 21 para empezar entonces fue
vacunación de la población de más no me
quieren minutos para terminar el
programa doctor frías como ve usted el
panorama a futuro como cree usted que va
a ser llegar a la cresta de esta ola del
segundo brote de kobe 19 en el
continente europeo va a ser un poco más
calmado va a ser un poco más manejable o
puede que esto todavía se salga de
control para las autoridades
yo espero
y así lo esperamos todos los
profesionales y sobre todo para todas
nuestras familias de que esto vaya
disminuyendo pero con la audencia con el
respeto de cada uno de nosotros que
estamos cada día saliendo de nuestras
casas y realizando lo mínimo que
podríamos intentar socializar y lo más
importante es la concientización de esto
es verdad que vivimos
tiempos donde queremos todo deprisa y
todo que tenemos que tener para allá o
como muchas veces decimos para ayer no
yo creo que vivimos en unas
circunstancias de máxima credibilidad de
circunstancias mejor dicho que no son
las ideales para nuestro día a día pero
necesitamos aspirar a que lo previsible
se obtenga lo mayor y que cada uno de
nosotros pongamos nuestro camino de
granito de arena
y que podamos salir de estos brotes de
este confinamiento y de esta bendita
pandemia que tenemos señor lópez su
conclusión rápidamente por favor
bueno primero que todo que entendamos
que el virus sigue ahí que no ha
desaparecido y tenemos que coexistir con
él y suplicar muchas medidas de
protección y mucho refuerzo a la
actividad de las autoridades sanitarias
para la detección precoz al aislamiento
de positivos para la realización de
pruebas como las únicas vías que tenemos
para frenar en estos momentos la
transmisión y la expansión y normalmente
es mucho lo que europa todavía nos puede
enseñar de este de esta segunda ola del
brote de el coronavirus en este
continente hay países con casos muy
particulares el manejo que le han dado
algunos países de la unión europea un
caso muy distinto ha sido el de suecia
que simplemente ha dejado que el virus
fluya tranquilamente a lo largo y ancho
de este país nórdico y otros países que
simplemente están poniendo restricciones
en algunos sectores en algunas
localidades en algunas regiones no de
una forma unificada a todo el territorio
nacional ya veremos cómo es el desenlace
de esta segunda ola a los dos invitados
les quiero agradecer por haber estado
con nosotros habernos colaborado con el
análisis y haber puesto sobre él
sus opiniones sobre este tema de ustedes
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros en sintonía el debate de france
24 pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas en las redes
sociales gracias siga con nosotros
[Música]